it's a huge trend these days of picking
animated classic films and making
live-action versions of them so today we
want to empower machine learning to help
us and generate what live-action
versions of animated classic films would
look like it's just a matter of time
until AI reboots all of our favorite
movies what's a character we can make
live action we can take Tom Hanks and
make Woody from Toy Story look like Tom
Hanks yeah we got Tom Hanks now we have
an image of Woody a character he plays
in Toy Story let's make a real man have
you guys ever heard of Runway ml it's
this program that is free to download
and it is basically a way for anybody to
experiment and create with machine
learning Niko has been messing around
with a lot like for months in the studio
and all of us have kind of just picked
it up and just been messing around with
it and it yields some super hilarious
results so this is really cool here's
how the process works basically we take
an input image of a face I feel like we
should do a buzz light here oh it's
right here all right
let's parse that face basically this is
gonna use AI to look at a person's face
and basically split it up into different
parts it's a skin the nose the eyes
eyebrows hair neck and give us a basic
image that shows us all the different
components of a face solids anything
from that we have to do this manually
boys man if your segmentation comes out
kind of janky like this you can actually
just take the same color and drawn by
hand so that the AI will recognize that
now it's skin it's identified all the
parts of the face and now what we're
gonna do is take those parts of the face
and give it a style image I think Tim
Allen's getting the booth
- melons cool but I think we need an it
guy take this Terry Crews Terry Crews it
could be a great buzz lay here here's
another face that we want you to
reference and rebuild this face in the
style of the first-base Sams rendering
with the clouds that allows you to use
cloud processing for these actions it's
computing everything on their GPU
servers their private machine learning a
private Nimbus their little nimbus on a
leash and that's what that's what runway
ml really is is that it's basically just
this huge repository of machine learning
networks algorithms and damn generative
adversarial networks Cruz oh no dude
that's pretty jacked up what did it do I
mean this looks like a scared what other
great animated movies deserve a reboot
the up grandpa grass is the way to get a
younger actor
oh yeah Marc perfect oh this is too good
up old man okay
all right we got a face okay we got
Danny DeVito mine
okay it looks like Stanley a little bit
ballon Newstalk who didn't really give
us a lot of information to work with
let's take another character will this
even work the proportions are all
different from a human I mean I think
I'll get this to work the mouth is
perfect the nose is almost there
we just need to add the eyes and shape
the face and we're good teenage mutant
ninja Regan is technically an animated
character do you think you'd make a
better fan OHS Joe Rogan as Thanos wow
he just looks like even meteor now who
would play Elsa from frozen they're
gonna reboot this live-action totally
pummeling definitely Tom Holland and I
think you'd be really like progressive a
young boy as a young woman very brave as
Elsa be brave
that actually like produced something
it's got like all the shading underneath
the neck in the neck it's actually easy
as far as like realistic faces that this
thing is generated so far this is the
closest yeah right Photography is great
Fogg Rafi okay so they're incredibly
similar it's basically using skin tone
hair color those really basic features
what other great animated movies deserve
a reboot yeah I freaking Ice Age baby
man who would play the Ice Age baby
it's about Adam driver leave a comment
if you agree to that Adam driver pays
ice age baby gonna be good he's got the
mouth and nose well enough I'm pushing
this one through guys oh except for the
giant like mutant like what do you make
Sam what's really cool is that like even
though the AI isn't perfect it knows how
to combine the elements at least in a
way that kind of makes it look like they
belong together you can draw like just a
skin circle right and it won't look like
anything but once you put the nose on
there the eye will actually know like
okay like I'm gonna contour and kind of
like emboss like the face to give you
those proportions and like shadows well
the guys are out there messing with
their AI face generation I thought it
would be fun to come back here and see
if I could play around with a little AI
myself now courtesy of today's sponsor
Vesey Footwear I actually have been
messing around with an AI shoe generator
and well quite frankly there's no way
that this thing has the computing power
to actually deliver this beautiful
magnificent shoe right here you see the
thing that AI can't do is come up with a
100% waterproof ready for any weather
sneaker not only can you wear these in
the mud
in the rain and the snow and the sleet
they're also made of a patented diamond
tex material meaning that they keep you
cool in the summer and keep you warm in
the winter when was the last time you
heard of AI doing that
I haven't another thing I can't do is
give you one of the most flexible
sneakers on the market I mean these
things are so stretchy and so
comfortable it feels like you're barely
even wearing a shoe you can wear this
hiking you can wear it on a date you can
wear it to the office so you could wear
it on run so if you guys are interested
in getting $25 off your own pair of
Betsy's head on over to Vesey Footwear
comm slash corridor crew and that's
exactly what you'll get 25 bucks off
Betsy Footwear comm slash corridor crew
they want to go for a run so the face
parks are here it's little janky as you
can see but that's because the face
parser is designed to take apart human
faces standard human faces that's what
it's trained for so we're throwing these
animated characters these CG characters
at it and it's really challenging Sam
you're basically using this parser to
automatically generate the face maps
yeah what I kind of want to do is
there's a different model that allows
you to hand draw what's cool about
manually drawing it is you can get more
details than this I think if I just
spend a little bit extra time really
taking an artist's touch to these
separations here you have some super
funny results I think we could get from
that and I want to try so obviously this
works best when it's going from a human
face to a human face so I want to test a
bunch of different configurations to see
how these games deal with human faces
okay all right so Nick and I are gonna
work on these little experiments here
unless we're done we're gonna show
everyone what we've made so yeah stay
tuned you know if you want to see us do
some other experiments with machine
learning we did a Tom Cruise defect in a
Keanu Reeves deep fake which are both
machine learning based visual effects
those videos are actually pretty cool so
go check them out if you haven't seen
them before
so we spent the last hours so just like
trying to whip together some cool things
so I was trying to explore like what it
would look like if I converted myself to
myself to this process this is it parsed
your face and then you gave it your own
face as an input to reconstruct it yeah
so then I tried combining Jenna so my
wife and I if we're to have a kid it's
gonna look like this sick disease like
decided to go through and convert
everyone to every once I took nine
photos of various other people because
I'm trying to get every possible
permutation of all of our faces here so
nine times nine that's 81 I should end
up with 81 different faces that are
generated this is Christian I found
Christian kind of interesting how he
just for whatever reason looks like a
Russian Eskimo because it's basically
forming it off of that one initial
parsed image so this is a plant that's
like really old leathery oil I'll take a
click to Niko
Dean Wow actually surprisingly spot-on
yeah you know didi Downey jr. this is
just a boy band I kept wondering why the
Huracan space was surrounded and then
all he just occurred to me is the beard
is converting your beard into awesome
yeah it's gotta be just going Oh looking
at like the hairstyle any tenders here
that that's fat long it's usually a
woman's hair good job Griffin for
confusing the AI so this one might be my
favorite
which celebrity does Nick look like
George you know it would be surprised if
there's elements of those actors really
being used for this picture because it's
probably trained I'm just as many
pictures as they can get and I'm sure a
lob is just that's a good point
Nico I'm Nico for whatever reason just
looks like an old lady
computers suck at this
Nick made some stuff
this is the first time I did a manual
segmentation from a picture of me and
this is what I got the first time weird
however I did a second time and I went
way more in detail with drawing myself I
really tried you know really good
actually it's really really how it's
like a hand drawn bike proportions
yeah and shaded realistically oh so this
is my face trained on an avatar picture
it's the same drawing the same
segmentation I do but I put in an avatar
that it's referencing instead of me
really tried to draw this one like this
is the one I took like 15 minutes really
trying to draw yeah it's that weird like
she like oh gosh this is creepy one
that's real and this is with like an
hour's worth of work imagine if we
actually put weeks into this what can we
create then honestly my take away from
this is that AI and machine learning is
accessible to everyone now and it's
super fun to mess around with it's just
super early days so it's like this stuff
is just constantly getting better and
better so we want to do a lot more of
this like machine learning and
exploration stuff and there are so many
more little programs to use within
Runway ml we haven't even scratched the
surface of what's available if you
checked it out find your favorite one
and let us know and maybe we'll take a
look at that what Bretton reads every
comment every single one especially the
videos that have eight thousand comments
there's actually another video coming
out soon that we've been working on for
a while a certain guy because my name is
Snoop Dogg he approached us because he
had a deep fake project he want us to
work on and we did it for his upcoming
music video the video will drop in the
music video drops it should be sometime
in the next week or two we're not
entirely sure so if you subscribe to the
channel you'll be the first one to see
it
let's just say it involves a certain
someone who's not with us anymore coming
also subscribe to see more of this thing
what the hell was there next time